And not even the Orthodox Easter
could bring a halt
to the fighting in Ukraine.
On Sunday, Ukrainian forces said
Russia had unleashed
an almost almost 100
shells of the past 24 hours
around back boats with around 30
firefights taking place.
Ukrainian and Russian fighters
are battling street by street
and house
by house for control of
what's now a pretty decimated city.
And there was, of course,
little joy on this Easter holiday.
130 Ukrainians are now free
after a prisoner exchange with Russia.
So that at least is some good news.
But there are many Ukrainians
who may never come home.
At the start of the war.
They fled
in the only direction that they could
and that was into Russia.
Now they're living
thousands of miles away
in Russia's Far East.
CNN Scott McLean
established contact with some of them
who describe their lives now
and why Ukrainians may not want them back
in the chaos of battle in
Mariupol, in eastern
Ukraine,
the civilians caught in
the crossfire had few good options.
They could either escape to Russia
or take their chances
as the war intensified.
Many of those who fled toward
Russia were encouraged
to live and work in the Far East.
From Rostov,
a 4000
mile train journey
to the edge of Siberia and a town
just a stone's throw from North Korea.
These are some of the first arrival
stepping off government
chartered trains a year ago.
Why does Russia want those people there?
That's a great question.
One is a propaganda benefit
Positioning these people as somehow
willingly seeking citizenship in Russia.
The second benefit is that Russia
simply needs bodies
in many parts of the country.
They don't have enough citizens
to make those municipalities function.
This hotel in the coastal town of Wrangel
was where new arrivals
will put up at first.
CNN reached
several of them through a telegram group
chat run by local volunteers,
keeping a log of resident requests
from baby food and toys to medicine.
Anyone dissatisfied with their stay
is told sarcastically
to take their complaints to Moscow.
The Kremlin. Putin.
The Russian
government has
long been eager
to populate its resource rich Far East,
and the state has tried
several experiments
to attract settlers,
including those from ex-Soviet states.
It now promises fleeing Ukrainians cash,
housing assistance, citizenship
and even free land
Though two people told CNN
they were struggling
to get the rent reimbursement
they say the government had promised.
Natalia was struggling
to find any housing at all,
hardly enthused by her new reality.
From, you know,
nothing's changed except the place.
But I no longer have a job that I love
in a home that I love more crack
rather than pop.
New arrivals
quickly had their Ukrainian
passports swapped for Russian ones.
Natalia figures she can't go back
it's almost only
because we are criminals there,
because those who left for Russia
are immediately
considered criminals
by the Ukrainian authorities.
So I'm forbidden to go there
at this point.
The absence of clarity
is the biggest problem
there is, understandably, within Ukraine,
a absolute outrage
against those
who are perceived as collaborators.
But the fact of the matter is
that we are dealing here
with the civilian population
that was seeking refuge in a time of war.
Under the terms of Russia's
relocation program,
the Ukrainians are required
to stay for at least three years.
One woman, Marina, told CNN
that after that, we will see.
It depends on the job
and material well-being.
So far, it's not very easy.
Another Valeria said plainly
that her family will stay in Russia.
And I don't even want to think
about Ukraine.
In a statement,
the Ukrainian prosecutor
general's office
told CNN that safety
and security of Ukrainian
citizens is a major priority
and that for many the only safe passage
was through Russia.
Of course,
they are not considered collaborators.
They need to get to a third
country and address
a local Ukrainian consulate.
It will issue them
Ukrainian documents to return to Ukraine.
But for those who remain in Russia
long term, the future is less clear
by Ukrainian law.
People who publicly deny occupation
or who call for support
for Russian actions
are considered collaborators.
International law prohibits
forcible transfers of people.
Russia says more than 5 million
Ukrainians have arrived in Russia
since the full scale war began.
And while Ukraine says
many were forcibly deported,
some, like Oksana, said they
went willingly
civil by nature.
We were
saving our own lives,
though they had few other options.
And Scott McClain joins us now.
Scott, did any of the individuals
that you and your teams spoke to?
Did they tell you
that they'd been forcibly deported? Yes.
And no one that we spoke to told us that.
And they all insisted
that they had gone by choice.
But also, remember that
we're talking about a group of people
that is, by and large, working class.
They speak Russian.
They have no ties to Europe.
And so
going to Russia
for most people was simply
the path of least resistance.
It is also very unlikely
that anyone that we spoke to
will be going back
to Ukraine any time soon.
They are allowed to go.
They're free to leave if they wanted to.
But if they stay for
less than three years in Russia,
they'll have to pay back
the state benefits that they've gotten,
which is out of reach for most people.
So now the big question mark is
what happens after three years
and by then will Ukraine
even want them back?
It's also impossible to know
just how freely people felt
that they could speak with us.
But you got the impression
from some of them
that they were on the side of Russia.
One woman told us that she
you know, as
the Ukrainians who are responsible for
what happened in Mariupol,
in other words,
said that she wanted to go back,
but only if it was firmly in the hands
of the Russians.
By then,
other people had more nuanced views
or didn't want to talk about the war.
I should also say quickly
that we did also reach out
to the Russian Ministry
of Internal Affairs,
but we didn't get any responses
to our questions from them.
Scott, thanks so much for joining us.
Ben, great to have you with us.
The city of Mahmoud still,
I guess, hangs.
It hangs in the balance
and fighting is intensifying.
Could you tell us
what the latest lines are
Yeah, I
learned that
Mahmoud is just barely hanging
in the balance at this point.
But first, let me explain to you
where I am
where in Sloviansk in eastern Ukraine,
not far from
not in front of that building
that last Friday was hit by an S-300
Russian surface to air missile.
The workers are still clearing away
the rubble.
This was the worst
single strike on Sloviansk
since the beginning of the full scale
Russian invasion more than a month ago.
15 people were killed in that strike
as far as Mahmoud goes.
The fighting is intensifying
the Russian Ministry of Defense
has put out a statement
claiming that
two new districts
have been taken in back mount.
And really,
the fighting
there is the most intense
in the entire front.
And what we saw the other day
is that
the authorities,
the police are trying desperately
to convince people
who are living in those areas
to move away from the fighting
as quickly as possible.
Another family is moving out,
leaving the frontline
town of Krasnodar, Rivka,
with the help of the police,
perhaps to lessen the blow
to his children.
Yevgeny quips, We'll be back.
It's just a vacation.
84 year old Raya doesn't
sugarcoat it.
It's like torture, she says.
But don't worry, we'll survive.
Raya has lived in Krasnodar.
Rivka all her life.
Rustam and his colleagues venture out
to these frontline villages
several times a week,
trying to convince people
to move to safer ground.
It's dangerous work, but first,
it's worth the risk
to get these children out of harm's way.
Looking into those eyes he asks,
What else can you do
in is if friendly persuasion
doesn't work?
There are other means.
There's an order from local government
requiring that children
be evacuated from areas
close to the fighting
unit.
This is
how Vasily
goes about the job of friendly persuasion
Sitting, talking,
trying to convince those
who remain that their lives are in peril.
The people in this basement
turned bomb shelter
have been down here for more than a year,
and clearly that has taken a toll
Their homes are here.
Everything they know is here.
They refuse to leave.
The eastern end of Krasnodar.
Rivka is the hardest hit
Yet even here,
there's a stubborn holdout.
They've come to this building
to try to convince an old man to leave.
They've already evacuated his wife.
As you can see, this area has been
seriously smashed by incoming rounds.
The Russians are just five kilometers
around three miles from here.
He didn't want his face
to appear on camera.
I'm not going anywhere, he says.
I was born here
and I'm going to die here.
The chances of that happening
here are perilously high.
And what makes it even more
perilous is the fact
that the Russians
are now using guided aerial bombs
which can be launched
50 kilometers from the front line.
And the Russians
apparently have no shortage
of those bombs.
Alena
All right, Ben Wedeman, thank you
very much.